hi everyone I'm David Griffin now
Michael Alexis Medina and supposed to
know this is our review of air or
belated review of arrow season 2 episode
late than never later never episode 19
the man under the hood and we got some
notes here don't we don't have notes
because you know not usually you know we
watch it together then we review it
right away it's been a few days you know
got game of thrones got different shows
on so stuff gets jumbled in the head so
I got some notes here to keep me on
track so this is a good episode there
were some that's some issues with this
episode I guess let's start with the H
let's let's start with the negatives we
always praised the show so much we loved
the show this was a good episode this
was based off a story written by believe
Guggenheim and Geoff Johns who we know
from DC Comics fame he's the head of DC
entertainment blah blah blah that's up
great guy but this felt like like you
were you point my key points at first it
felt like almost two episodes two
different shows even colliding with each
other i'm not sure if at all yeah worked
out now let's let's start by star i got
my notes let's talk about the flash
stuff which is some of the biggest
things here we have killer frost is
introduced her name is I want to say cat
llings the game of thrones caitlin snow
and a vibe francisco ramon these are the
comic book characters that are going to
be these are the cast members that are
going to be in the flash series which is
fine but that scene in the beginning at
the warehouse like you said it felt a
little out of place looks like you know
that that was a problem I had one of the
first things and I'm not familiar with
the actors playing killer frost and yeah
I'd maybe they're good actors I just one
of the first things that stood out to me
was the acting was not quite on par with
what I'm used to seeing now that could
have just been directing that could have
just been the dialogue the dialogue was
pretty weak during that sale really just
stood out seemed a little cheesy a
little this forced it really you know
stuck out like bad way right even like
Felicia Felicity when she came in even
she came in and said oh these are the
people I met the law and it's like and
then it's like Oh flash and then oh he's
hanging out iris now it's like if now
granted and a lot of you who watch our
reviews are familiar with the arrow Siri
arts our era with flash and the DC
Comics you'll know Irish his name but
that's a little bit of fanservice like
if you don't know who i mean just
throwing irises name out doesn't mean
anything his first of all we haven't met
the character yet we know she's cast
she's casted we haven't met her yet so
it's like just throwing that out
they're just it felt kind of wasted felt
like that was a little unnecessary I do
like the fact that they are dropping all
this little flash goodness you know
because we're too flashy I like that
because if anything it just hints at the
future of the both franchises you
creating this whole DC Universe and so I
know that I believe they were talked
about was our man you lead a future
doing something like that so if anything
I'm excited for that but the whole yeah
iris just felt like you know it's it's
bound to happen right here on the show
Justin you know didn't need to be
necessary thing but just think we're
seeing killer frost killer frost isn't
usually a good guy no no yeah she's part
of the she's usually a villain but in
her story like she goes to Nauticus I'm
bad happen so I don't know what they're
gonna I'm not gonna go that far like I
wonder if she's going to start bad and
be good or be good and go bad or maybe
those keep her good the whole time I
don't know what sugar characters gonna
be like I mean like with most TV shows
films and stuff they always just like
you know kind of like to mess with us or
what not and sometimes it works out
sometimes it doesn't it was the thing
with the the sonic gun a little the wave
gun yeah with it that's it they also
make a reference to dr. light dr. light
you know so that was kind of cool that
kind of I was excited for dr. right I'm
can talk I like dr. light so that could
be fun hopefully we'll see him I'm sure
we will on the flash Syria that was kind
of cool but again that whole scene as a
whole just really stood out like I said
just yeah not in a good way like I said
for me I felt like it was like two shows
on top of each other trying to compete
I'm like wait this isn't air like what
soon as a wet in that factoring like
this doesn't feel like an arrow episode
it feels like we're mixing the whole
vibe and I don't differently when I
watched it please you know I know you
know some comics but I don't I didn't
get the connection to killer frost in
the vibe and tony little research went
on you know the DC Comics wiki and
looked everything up so I mean I didn't
even know what's going on I'm like wait
Catlin like they met him at start at a
central city yeah like what does that
mean and but then you know I guess you
do a little research you find out so
also I want to talk about Isabel rochev
talk about summer glau you know the
lovely summer glau is now in the
forefront of everything after a long
high right a lot of you had theories a
lot of you saw pictures of her well if
we should talk about that you know let's
talk about that and we're going to talk
about sunday at the end then i'm going
to call a spoiler section even though
it's not spoilers it's something that's
on the web there's some photos released
of characters
that will you know summer glau was in
particular we'll talk about the end now
we do know that summer without this is
not a spoiler she was twitched at the
end so we know that she's yeah alive her
eyes are open that blood transfusion
yeah she's tuition she hasn't met Miroku
and there's I think that all worked out
uh no III was not surprised obviously
and we'll get to that we'll be right
there i will write to see that but it
was just cool is great way to end uh
this episode this particular episode um
I I felt that like it was kind of it was
great episode I just felt like maybe cuz
the events of like last week's episode
yeah we're just I loved last week's
episode yeah I just thought it was kind
of a step back but now that's saying
that wasn't bad oh really enjoyed the
episode as a whole but like seeing her
finally become like take that next step
yeah definitely had me geeking out for a
little bit now for me probably the
coolest part of the episode for me was
just seeing Deathstroke in the I don't
know the underground there there there
his Batcave that was my fav asian of the
club episode which is cool you just wait
and there's like welcome home be like oh
crap and takes down everybody I mean
that's what I loved about it because it
was just well done because it was short
but sweet it was at a point I wanted to
make it wouldn't impact yeah he wanted
thats get that skeleton key right but he
also i think one to prove a point which
he did he just beat everybody like I
took all you guys down I got it I know
exactly where you guys live yeah
everything you are so that was good I
mean it's great to see industrial come
any Burnett's doing such a good job as
great seeing him do his thing let's talk
about now some of you said is
interesting that a leash sister is
slowly becoming possibly the new Laurel
in a way yes not bad I like her but if
we just seen her was she like again as
we always do in the bar she's the only
person that works at this club you know
just you know stack and lick her up and
you know talking it out when you know
she seems like she's kind of come to
terms with everything a little bit more
ya know she has but again you're
absolutely right the whole like Laurel
connection and so just because again
she's kind of like become this damsel in
distress and I understand she's not
really superhero she's right emotions
called speedy she's not really exactly i
just think right now there's just i
don't know if it's just sometimes a
little heavy with
the drama to where it's almost a little
cheesy like with the whole like you know
also your dad knew all along their
daughter like I just kind of laying it
on a little thick right you know for me
at least but again it's just she's not
really serving a purpose other than just
to create some drama yeah right now and
I do like her and I want to see him I I
definite like a more than Laurel yeah
yeah she's kind of bored behind right
and Laura was more port proactive in
this episode to a point still again it's
so silly because if this is a column
this is the comic book world so we know
this is how it is but when she was
recalling when she's seen her sister
like when they were together in the in
the previous episode when she birds of
prey or two episodes ago when they when
he say when she saved her and she like
looked it's like oh that's who that is
like really you stress blonde hair that
Jim do the the cleft chin you really
didn't know that was her I mean I know
it's a comic world Clark Kent puts on
the glasses you know what they're super
light it's just it's funny I mean she
was being a detective like I look she's
gonna go dark side seems like she's
letting everything go like those who
everybody is and she's except like she
hugged Ali and said you know they'll be
interesting to see where they go from
there because yeah like you said I mean
she kind of made amends with it you know
she's like I'm just gonna take my dad's
advice you just said like you know he's
it should matter who the arrow is right
now me he's a symbol and that's all that
really matters again I think it's
interesting that her dad still hasn't
quite put those you know pray together
but whatever that that's it I don't want
to know I don't know so it's cool that
she kind of just like what she's at
peace she's cool with it but is she
really good with it like I can't see her
just like walking away be like I'm good
read it right you know cuz like where do
you take this character from that I know
we've been talking since like you know
last season about her becoming Black
Canary is gonna happen is it not I still
think there's a chance all right good no
not a lot of you out there thinking that
there might not be a good idea cuz lotus
is that interesting right now yeah you
know I think it's two names katie your
loan from Miss Brown surname the actress
who plays black an area it's doing such
a good job with that she's really good
so keep it on the ladies so we're going
to go and do I don't call it spoiler
territory because this stuff's out on
the web we're gonna start talking about
possibly what could be happening in
future episodes that we've seen photos
of online so if you don't want to know
about that
you get off now so specifically we're
going to talk about summer glau is
character Isabel rochev she is beach is
a they basically made her a combination
of a few characters so let's talk about
there's two characters here's Isabel
rochev and it's also rose wilson who was
Slade's Wilson's Deathstroke's
illegitimate daughter yeah um who mostly
has run-ins it sounds like with Teen
Titans yeah see she's well first we say
she's Ravager rap well we've seen the
photos of furniture no Isabel rochev in
the comics is not ravager she's the head
that she is the queen of Queen industry
she wants to she does have beef with
ollie she did have an affair with her
father we started with Oliver's father
Robert Queen yeah and has vengeance on
ollie but she's not ravager now Rose
Wilson is ravager this is an interesting
thing just doing research go to the DC
wiki look that up some so much good
stuff on there there's been four
different Ravagers ya later on with the
Sun that's kind of like what kicked off
and kind of merged Slade Deathstroke to
begin with and then there's a
brother-in-law or brother or something
that had some beef with them then this
is like a Ravager those in like a Batman
comic and now there there's Rose Wilson
is a little tournament daughter so
they're combining two characters so we
think about the whole combination of the
two characters there again it works for
me just because I mean Isabel rochev is
a cool character but is she at least for
TV for this universe is she is strong
enough character kinda stand on her own
I think we saw with Billy wintergreen
last season as you know if you're
familiar with Deathstroke I'm like his
Alfred right around so they kind of made
him like his partner in crime know so I
thought that was kind of cool kind of
answers just to get his character in
there in the first place so I thought
this was a good idea because I mean in
the show isn't Deathstroke you know it's
not cold so you're not gonna be all of
the time to you know introduce the Sun
and go that route so I think you know
kind of cut to the chase I love summer
glau on the show so I'm excited I have
no problems with it and I still kind of
think that she's not going to be his
daughter now said they wonder backs were
so she was already having an affair yeah
with Robert Queen before the island
before Deathstroke ever met him so I
don't think I think she's going to be
Isabel rochev ass but she's going to
also be ravager now that she has all of
her the mirakuru yeah inside of her so
it'll be interesting I mean again we're
getting towards the Emily a four-episode
yeah yeah
we're almost there it's let's not forget
Roy that was pretty i was i was big
stuff right there because I mean you
know in the last episode he takes off
you just can't with the pressure ya
can't hit anymore and so this episode we
find out that Slade and Isabel have
captured them yeah they've got him tied
up to that machine i forgot what it was
called in the air here basically it's
extracting here the blood which has no
kuro and injecting it in all these
soldiers yeah you know I mean he's
adding art but we don't really know
where he's going that's yet seem leaving
town and they captured in the no worries
going to understand them it'll be
interesting to see to what happens to
Roy because will this affect him in any
way you know like as I know he did
alvord was able to get him I just attach
them from the machine before any real
damage was right right you know I mean I
think enough was you know still gonna
happen but regardless it'd be
interesting to see if this affects him
in any way because he's already kind of
mentally messed up anyways yeah
definitely um and to you know both you
and I both like the position you talk
about the beginning of the episode yeah
but how was interesting to see arrow
team go on the offensive absolutely the
first time actually ahead of waiting to
happen actually went after destra or at
least Queen consolidated yeah exactly
well like I said you know Slade has
become this Cerebral Assassin rare yeah
really been attacking Oliver in
different ways right right you know so
for them to kind of finally like look at
this is actually belief Felicity's plan
you know to kind of go find it was kind
of fun singer actually go out in the
field and stuff but yeah for them to
kind of take it to Slade and in turn
kind of provokes late a gram right it
was kind of cool you know at least it
shows that they're fighting back there
they're done being you know pushover so
you know how that plays out we'll see so
I mean you know again we're almost done
four episodes left yeah will you know
Moira become mayor that's what everybody
wants to know it's a restock who's gonna
win the mayoral race you know the
campaign uh also you know Deathstroke
we're gonna see the big battle I know we
keep getting teased but we know the big
battles gonna happen we have if you're
still here you're sorry Senor spoiler
sections are going to talk about we're
going to see ravager is going to come
we're gonna see what Isabel's gonna do
what that battle is going to be like
maybe they'll keep her around maybe
she'll turn good maybe slate alternate I
don't know we'll see a lot of stuff
going on a lot of good times to be had
they're gonna go straight for more weeks
straight
no breaks no finally know like two or
three weeks off thank goodness so thanks
for sticking with us our review of this
week let us know what you think we think
about the whole you know Isabel rochev
thing the whole combination of her and
Rose will wilson and that whole
combination let us know what you think
about you know the flash actors what do
you think about their introduction was
it Mike and I thought was a little
forest didn't leave blending with the
episode well but I'm excited to see them
in the flash series I just don't know if
it work hopefully that won't transition
yeah I hold it a little bit better right
so you know as always when you come find
us think hero calm we're also on Twitter
to when I'm asks any questions Dennis me
Michael just ask us anything about DC
Universe so what favorite comic movies
you want to see you know spider-man is
coming up pretty soon you can find us at
think hero i'm at griffin de nom at mr.
Michael Alexis yeah also check us out on
this YouTube page here make sure you
subscribe like it spread the word it's
where I think hero pro and also on
Facebook of a facebook page and that's
facebook.com slash think you're a fan so
this again spread the word social media
and we will see you next week
you